[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here in San Carlos you can't just the
jump on the train jump on a subway jump
on a light rail and go to the multiplex
I think sometimes Native adults have
said all native kids they're losing
their culture to him really lost
anything they just want access to goods
and services like everyone else just
open the shop come check it out
patchy agency means a lot you know it's
a hub for the skaters here the younger
generation is the key you got a psych
them up get them motivated again hype
that's the key to the future the Apache
team Doug Trey Elijah P Reuben Irwin
Tasha Rozelle Keith the ones that are
not here the new members
they're heavy cats they didn't get good
by accident they got good on purpose
there are the ones out on the street
getting bloody getting tore up but
they're the ones also smoking out kids
and teaching kids you know it's cool and
it's fun to skate fun to be yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
my great grandmother whom is still life
she had to endure such a tremendous
amount of pain for me to even live and
then that pain followed to my mother
it could have followed me but it didn't
wherever you you're from it's not gonna
dictate where you're going I think
that's why it's really moving for me to
connect my culture with you know my
skateboard culture because I realized
that there's a rich pungent aura that
I'm supposed to carry to transfer to
touch the little girl's heart that needs
it and that needs to get told hey you're
special you're gonna change the world I
am my ancestors and the walking and
embodiment of everything that they were
do they are if I don't walk in the path
that's been put before me then I'm not
fulfilling the path that they wanted me
to fulfill in the first place when I see
little artists hands I see the hands of
artists I'm looking at my öhlins and
mortality and when a minute he touches
my hand and my hand touches his he's
touching eternity
that's why grandparents have such a
great love for their grandkids he's me
53 years ago I'm him 53 years from now
[Music]
so in tumultuous political time it's
good to unplug take a step back and look
around you and look at the family that
you have look at the friends that you
have go visit your neighbor go take some
food to your mom go chop wood for your
dad go help someone and don't put it on
social media don't tell everybody what
you did because when you do those things
here you're helping your world the
greatest leaders have always been the
most generous leaders they've given and
some leaders some of the greatest
leaders give their life why did I decide
to spend my last 30 years working for
young people in my community I want
young people to live I want young people
to see their own potential and I want my
community to go into the next century
strong and bold and courageous my art
took me to the DeYoung museum in San
Francisco to do work with friends in the
South Bronx to the hallowed halls of
Columbia University
but I stay here in San Carlos birth an
important skateboard brand here on the
rest
you
[Music]